Poland's Prime Minister Donald Tusk takes
over from Herman Van Rompuy on the first of
December as the new President of the European
Council at a pivotal time in the EU's history.
The challenges ahead are formidable. Europe's
economies are only slowly recovering from
the financial crisis. Unemployment is high.
Conflict is simmering in neighbouring Ukraine.
So Tusk has more than a full-time job on his
hands in Brussels, with tasks that are highly
political and often technical, and he will
also chair summits of leaders in countries
using the euro currency.
As a first step, the Polish premier must give
up all political posts at home.
He now presides over the European Council,
whose members - the leaders of the EU's 28
nations have elected him.
The Council sets the EU's political direction
and priorities. But it also handles crisis
management - whether it be economic or in
times of conflict - when decisions must be
taken at the highest level.
Careful planning is a key to success, as the
president prepares and chairs the summits,
and drives work forward. It's a job that requires
great political skill and an ability to forge
consensus from 28 points of view.
"The interest of each state coincides with
the interests of the European Union.
If there wasn't a willingness to reach an agreement, to find a comprise,
if we didn't have that political will, we wouldn't make it.
So it's my role to facilitate
all that."
Tusk has a mandate for two and a half years.
His term can be renewed once.
The Council has four scheduled summits annually
in Brussels but generally meets more often.
In the days that follow them, the president
reports to the European Parliament on the
results.
His office is in Brussels but the president
also represents the EU on the wider international
stage, along with the European Commission
president and High Representative.
He is the face of the Union, at summits with
major world powers and at the UN General Assembly.
"I represent the Union at the highest level.
So what I do is to preside
over meetings that we call our summits with our strategic partners.
These are important meetings."
These tasks, and more, await Donald Tusk - only
the second President of the EU's most powerful
institution - when he takes his bow in Brussels
on the first of December.